ça me paraît excessivement douteux de
procédés de faire du mode du christ
encore nous dans les régions que l'on
passé à la casserole des régions vont
avoir autant de représentations qu'avant
voyons ce qui se serait passé au
lendemain des élections de 2014 si le
québec réformer le mode de scrutin comme
le propose le pq la cac et québec
solidaire
supposons qu'on conserve exactement le
même nombre de sièges à l'assemblée
nationale et le même nombre de députés
dans chaque région du québec avec des
élections proportionnel mixte
compensatoire
les libéraux pourraient gagner ces
sièges de moins
voyons maintenant ce que ça donne en
région avec un exemple la région de
l'estrie laisserai compte cinq
circonscriptions en 2014
les cinq comtés ont été remportés par
les libéraux qui ont pourtant obtenu 40
% du vote dans la région
dans l'hypothèse d'une proportionnel
mixte compensatoire l'estrie pourrait
toujours avoir cinq députés
la différence c'est qu'il n'y aurait que
trois très vaste circonscription
les deux autres sièges seraient
attribués à des candidats provenant
d'une liste électorale
supposons que dans une proportionnelle
mixte compensatoire le plq remporte les
trois comtés toujours avec 40 % du vote
et bien pour compenser le fait que le pq
et la caq ont respectivement obtenu en
2014 30 et 20 % des votes
le modèle compensatoires aurait accordé
un siège au pq et un autre à la caq
l'estrie aurait donc toujours le même
nombre de représentants à l'assemblée
nationale
mais au lieu d'avoir cinq députés
libéraux comme en 2014 il y en avait eu
trois choisit directement dans les
circonscriptions qu un pic historique à
kystes provenant d'une liste électorale
donc une répartition des sièges en
fonction des intentions de vote des
électeurs de la région
[Musique]